good morning believe nation today's
message is watch me over to you Tyra
Banks even as a model back in my
modeling days I'd say almost every
single day I heard you can't do this
fashion show because you're black you
can't do that magazine spread because
you're black you can't have this
contract modeling contract because
you're black you can't be on the cover
of a magazine because you're black and
of course they get you down but for some
reason there's something inside of me
that goes you say I can't really watch
me so when life and in business you're
going to get people who tell you all the
reasons why your ideas are not going to
work out the point out all your flaws
will point out all the weaknesses in
your plans and make you feel like you're
weak and you can't do anything I call
these people the little main they're too
afraid to go and take some big step in
their life and instead they're jealous
and they attack people we're trying to
make something great with their own and
so you can either listen to them you can
either continue to live the life that
you have continued live the small life
and not reach for anything greater or
you can use their feedback as fuel to
help you dry forward you could tell them
yeah watch me when I dedicated myself to
youtube and said you know what I'm going
to go all in on YouTube now I made a
video as a collaboration that was really
impressed by and I was really excited by
one and start promoting it and I sent it
to somebody I knew who had a lot of
experience in the video industry and he
hated it he said it would never work he
said it was too long he said nobody
would ever watch a six-minute video and
that would never work out he told me
that I didn't understand the internet
fast forward to today that video has
over a million views has let the tons of
subscribers have really helped boost in
my account and it's something that I am
proud to have been involved with what
have I listened to that guy what if I
thought you know he has all this
experience maybe he's right maybe I
shouldn't include it maybe I'll pull it
down and do the safe thing that's the
risk and the challenge a lot of people
face and you have to eliminate the
little man from your life and when you
get that negative feedback and criticism
use it to push you forward use it as
fuel to then go out and tell the little
man just watch me believe so my question
the day today is I want to know a little
man in your life who you've had to say
just watch me to you don't just say the
name but tell me the story because i
want to get inspiration from it and I
think it'll inspire other people as well
leave it in the comments below thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shock events recipes away
Express dokey beegly this rental TV I
work